ich habe mir dazu ein paar punkte
aufgeschrieben wie hat meine traumfrau
aussehen sollte und die laut eigentlich
wie folgt ich kann euch das ja auch kurz
vorlesen
hey leute was knapp und jetzt bekommen
bei myvideo bevor er fragt also ich war
grad kurz duschen kann man ja sagen also
ich war wirklich duschen und meine haare
sind lang
deswegen habe ich dir jetzt einfach so
gelassen wundert euch nicht sonst hab
ich dir immer hoch aber egal heute ist
halt so ihr könnt ja meine kommentare
schreiben ob das scheiße aussieht oder
ob das gut aussieht wie bestimmt schon
hier unten oder oben und am titel
gelesen habt geht es heute um meine
traumfrau ich habe mir dazu ein paar
punkte aufgeschrieben wie hat meine
traumfrau aussehen sollte und die lauten
eigentlich wie folgt ich kann euch das
ja auch kurz vor lesen also passt auf
sie sollte 1 1 70 groß seien 650 kilo
wiegen braune augen haben der bund muss
22 cm unter der nase seien nicht 2,3 cm
dann ist es halt zu viel
die augenbrauen sollten 11 zentimeter
über den augen sein werden jetzt halt 10
zentimeter wer es zu wenig 12 cm ist so
viel ist doch klar
sie sollte auf jeden fall blonde haare
braune haare ist auch sie solche frauen
einfach beides zusammen irgendwie so oft
weg sind aber die haare dürfen auch
nicht länger als 29 cm seien 28 ist noch
bei 27
also preis ist ein echt zu viel und wenn
diese punkte nicht erfüllt werden dann
mach ich halt wieder schluss sein es ist
nicht mal meine traumfrau ist ja klar
nein das war es jetzt noch nicht
außerdem sollte okay das war jetzt
natürlich nur spaß
also wer das jetzt geglaubt hat er hat
es geglaubt
nein ich denke nicht dass ihr das
geglaubt habe es war jetzt zwar nicht so
witzig wie es sein sollte aber es war
auch nicht schlecht oder
naja leute es ist halt so dass immer
wenn ich irgendwo frage egal ob es jetzt
auf instagram ist instagram egal ob sie
jetzt auf instagram snap chat youtube
sonst twitter benutzt sich ja nicht so
egal irgendwo halt kommt wirklich immer
10.000 fragen von wegen alex wie sieht
denn deine traumfrau aus da denke ich
mir
das verstehe ich schon ich meine wenn
man ein video macht oder ich hab ja ein
video gemacht was meter nicht tragen
sollten weltuntergang dann wird einem
10.000 also diesmal wirklich 10.000 mal
das war 10.000 mal gesagt
und du bist von oberflächlich und
scheiße aber dann soll ich ein video zu
meiner tropf vormachen ich meinen wo ist
denn da jetzt sinn oder der unterschied
wie sieht sieht deine traumfrau aussehen
aussehen ist ja halt so nett so halt
sehen aussehen nur das äußere ist ja nur
außen nicht innen und auch oberflächlich
oder nicht versteht ihr das ergibt doch
0 sind dass er gibt wirklich keinen sinn
an dieser stelle mache ich nicht mein
name mal ehrlich wenn jetzt irgendwer
von euch da draußen seine perfekte
traumfrau oder seinen perfekten
traummann beschreiben kann
dann meldet euch mal bei mir ich meine
wir können gerne um eine million euro
wetten die frau oder der mann halt mit
dem ihr dann euer leben verbringen
werdet nicht so aussieht also wenn das
halt nicht so ist dann kriege ich eine
million euro wäre es dabei ja ich meine
wenn ich jetzt sagen würde meine
traumfrau sieht so und so und so aus und
ich mir zwei wochen später irgendeine
klären würde die halt nicht so aussehen
würde dann würde ich dann natürlich
sagen pass auf stopp ich habe vor zwei
wochen in einem youtube video gesagt
dass meine traumfrau so und so aussehen
sollte und du siehst halt nicht so sorry
verpiss dich ganz einfach ich meine bis
auf ihr könnt ihr euch meinen dazu in
die kommentare schreiben wie seht ihr so
das ganze thema schreibt in die
kommentare ansonsten würde mich freuen
wenn ihr daumen nach oben damals wenn
ihr das so sehen die ich dann lasst auf
jeden fall jetzt einen daumen nach oben
da wir sehen uns dann schon am keine
ahnung also jetzt kommen immer drei
videos die woche die kommen also zwei
videos kommen wir irgendwann in der
woche und sonntag absolut bleibt halt
ganz normal
also immer schön wach bleiben wann mein
neues video online kommt dann direkt
absteigen samstag war es eingeblendet
es geht so weiter mit meinem könnt ihr
gerne abschrecken wir auf jeden fall
cool und yahoo.com ich muss jetzt ich
hab jetzt aufs mikrogramm schuldig